closing arguments are set to begin today
in the case of a Colorado man accused of
killing his fiancee Patrick Frazee is on
trial for the murder of Kelsie Bharath
she was last seen in public Thanksgiving
Day a year ago her body has still not
been found testimony wrapped up on
Friday with claims that phrase he also
tried to have the star witness his
former lover killed Niki batiste has
been following this story for a long
time she's outside the courthouse in
[ __ ] Creek Colorado Nikki good
morning what do we expect when do we
expect this case to go to trial
well Tony good morning the jury of seven
women and five men is expected to begin
deliberations today the prosecution
presented more than 60 witnesses the
defense called none and Patrick Frazee
declined to testify cameras have not
been allowed in the courtroom but our
CBS affiliate reporter was inside for
the latest twist in this trial I think
the evidence they've presented and some
of the testimony we've heard has been
almost a bombshell in this rural
Colorado town KKTV reporter Ashley
Franco has listened to every detail in
Patrick Frazee's murder trial the
prosecution believes Patrick Frazee is a
cold calculated manipulative murderer a
fellow prisoner became a surprise
witness when he testified that he
received 16 notes from Frazee with
instructions to use his prison gang
connections to have several of the
witnesses testifying against Frazee
killed including Bharath smother people
who testified against Patrick crazy in
the trial a lot of them were on that hit
list the list also included the
prosecution's star witness and Frazee's
secret girlfriend idaho nurse Krystal
Lee Lee testified that Frazee told her
he beat his fiancee to death with a
baseball bat on Thanksgiving Day after
the murder
Lee says Frazee called her and said she
had a mess to clean up Lee claims she
drove from Idaho to Colorado and cleaned
up the crime scene she said that she did
what she did for Patrick Frazee because
she loved him Barris remains have never
been found
neither has a murder weapon
investigators say Frazee's motive was
custody of the couple's now too
old daughter with the evidence they've
been presented with the testimony
they've been presented especially with
the last witness on the prosecution side
I think a lot of us are thinking a day
or two until we have a verdict until we
have a verdict
Patrick Frazee faces life in prison if
convicted in exchange for her testimony
Lee agreed to plead guilty to evidence
tampering she'll be sentenced after
freezies case wraps up and faces a
maximum of three years in prison
Anthony Frazee and Bharath daughter is
with Barriss parents well that's good to
hear it'll be very interesting to see
what the jury makes of all this Nikki
thank you